minable pour commencer puisque on va
essayer d'être un peu sur le tchat et
discuter avec les sur le deuxième il va
faire un copier-coller en fait du coup
alors loach est ce qui est la rage me
suis planté dans l'ouverture j'ai
l'impression allez on fait d'un match 5
c'est pas bon relook chess peut-être
déjà très mal à voir quoi qu'il se passe
nous sommes toujours en place
bon déjà envoyé 5n plus et j'ai envie
d'envoyer 4 c'est un pas l'air de casser
des briques
j'ai un peu peur là quand même mais bon
et on verra faut qu'elle fut en fait la
gente dame à quatre pions prend qui on
prend pions prend pions prend roi prend
damas est roi c'est cissé je pense que
je suis safe
en plus j'ai le pion aux deux qui
contrôle d un fils jamais laissons le
calculer quoi qu'il se passe calcul kg 5
qui est bon
oui
en tête on est quand même très mal en
fait pas terrible ce qu'on a fait
en tête faire en échec en premier ici
on est mal
on est foutu allure f7 qui tomba à on
est déjà foutu bon bah écoutez j'ai très
mal joué
non j'ai du mal à me concentrer à faut
que je rentre dans le truc après après
avoir commenté pendant 12 heures ou 13
heures en deux jours c'est un peu dur
quoi il faut rentrer dans le tournoi et
seniors
ben c'est complètement fou tu quand même
qu'est-ce que j'ai mal joué mais d'un
match en cinq sets est mauvais je savais
mais bon j'ai pas pensé que ce serait si
grave
on a une qualité de moi commence par
faire une première erreur déjà prendre
la fuite quand tu as encore une une
fourchette c'est pas terrible fait une
première erreur mais bon il va falloir
qu'il en fasse beaucoup pour qu'on
remonte à faire ce qu'on peut un fonds
l'arnaqué avec une pièce de moi on est
peut-être on peut on peut encore être en
confiance on peut encore être en
confiance
à voir ce que ça donne une pièce deux
mois derrière fois est ce que cette fois
ci on va c'est qu'une qualité mais la
position est vraiment bien courir
on va avoir mis à peut-être aussi un peu
la pression qui sait
alors apprendre merci il faut il faut de
toute façon un objet de prendre un peu
de risques là d'essayer toujours un peu
vite essayer de faire un peu d piège
puisque on part de loin
donc il faut que j'essaye de jouer vite
quand je pense avoir deviné ça j'avais
calculé fou à 5
du coup ça me permet de jouer tempo
mais peut-être cavaliers ici mais bon je
tête des trucs de fouine accueille des
trois banques et les trois quand même
des six échecs
car on évite plus tôt il va pas prendre
ici
pas de bol je pas de voir ce que kiev
karaté chèque qui prend des saints qui à
tour ses 5
je vais faire kébé 4
malgré on essaye de fouiner fawkes alpha
suffisant place et est ce que ça le fait
ça marche pas trop pour le moment
pour le moment ça fonctionne pas aïe aïe
aïe
vers tours 5
ouais je pense que je vais la perdre
sanaa
il n'y a pas assez de deux pièces et a
pas assez de jeu bien joué et joue pas
mal à élever par alain
qui prend 1,6 est fou prend des deux
à prendre une fois à faire flamber 6
c'est bien joué ça aussi tour c4
mais c'est de mettre le foulard on va
essayer d'envoyer les pions
on va essayer d'envoyer les pions
si on peut jamais fait de mettre la tour
sur la huitième jeu les corriger le tir
maintenant
ok j'en vois
euh ok je pousse
les gens voient encore
j'envoie caisse pas grave si on prend ce
pion en fait je m'en fous complètement
je voyais a encore une fois
ok je trouvais du contre je inespéré vu
la position de base
je pensais pas pouvoir avoir autant de
contres jeu
ok maintenant
j'ai maintenant un tour ici infos ici
je suis quand même complètement foutu et
j'ai plus de temps en plus
pas de chance
[Musique]
pas de chance aïe aïe aïe
j'aurais dû la gagner
j'aurais dû la gagner j'ai pas joué
assez vite
pas de chance pas de chance part de
chance pas de chance j'étais un peu long
j'étais un peu trop lent non mais j'ai
presque failli faire arnaquer cette
finale
moi j'ai réussi à marquer sur
l'échiquier elle aurait dû mieux la
jouer à la fin joue un peu plus vite
aïe aïe aïe c'est dommage c'est dommage
de ne pas l'avoir gagné
c'est donc avec cette qualité de moi on
avait trouvé le contre jeu on avait on
s'était bien battu quoi on partait de
loin
non elle est trouvée le con tre jeu on
avait c'était bien débrouillé aïe aïe
aïe
qu'est ce qui me fait la fred tu pas
trop ce qu'ils m'envoient là il n'a pas
développé ses pièces il m'attaque le roi
moi j'avais fait les deux pions passé
liées et/ou peut-être quand j'ai poussé
jeantet dû pousser à lever 3 avant à
trois je sais plus on était tellement
proche avec une des classes faible de
partout là on va prendre une fois ici
par katrina c'est de gagner le fou un
peu bizarre le plan connais beaucoup de
temps de perdu pour les noirs du conte
va proposer les changes des dames on va
la jouer comme si on jouait aux échecs
propres
on échange un peu tout on est là tous
rangs je viens de prendre ici avant elle
met de la tour en d1 après celle là plus
tôt
je pense qu'on vise pas mal quand même
ah c'est dommage on était pas loin on
n'était pas loin de l'arnaqué totalement
celle là la précédente m'en aller on
peut aller prendre le pion h5 mais ce
qu'on a vraiment besoin
pour le moment on va doubler les tours
avec m6 échec
quel idiot un marrant d'être aussi
idiots
hello alexandre entre la princesse
alexandre la princesse qu'est ce que
c'est que ce pseudo
alexandre la princesse sûrement pas le
pseudo en fait
alexandra la princesse alexandra
alexandria la princesse à alexandria
princesse je suis en sueur en lisant ton
pseudo alexandrie absente princesse je
suis en sueur total à comment faire
affaire qui est b5 et joyeuses fêtes à
toi aussi
faut que je prenne des cours de lecture
de pseudo sera la partie précédente j'ai
encore en travers de la gorge
et c'est de faire crisser 4006
pour aller encaisser le pion des 5
du coup on va faire des 5-6 laisse
l'occasion de deux poussées à lui verser
6 donc l on va prendre des cinq fred
power en sueur
les trois options passer à l'est on
enchaîne les parties
à enjeu contre et anne voilà on va lui
refaire ça comme la fois on va jouer
faut prendre dame prend des cinq
maintenant du coup alors à jouer un truc
un peu hybride envoyé l'adamant h5
on va remettre est un an sur
thain qui a du mal
à tout envoyer d'analysé
alors
comment est-ce que ça va se passer cette
histoire
et ce qui éteint et en sueur déjà je
sens et annonce sur sks qui va oser
aller prendre une tour non ils osent pas
et thann qui commence la défense
lê thanh qui commence à se défendre
quand on attaque
commencé quand même j'ai 4 mars qui fait
croître quand je serai dommage cinq
cavaliers age 2 d'arâches 4 ok vient ici
ça me parait soupçonnant comme coup
ça me paraîtrait soupçonnant je vais
faire 5-3 jeu ça me parait soupçonnant
enfin je veux ça il veut prendre de
l'espace au centre me libérer le fou
préparer du fou des six
jean faut plutôt et
ça n'a pas fonctionné je vais faire
thierry prend des cas tout reprend j'ai
quatre cavaliers pranger quatre échecs
mais y'a roigé de dommage ça aurait été
beau
ça marche pas
enfin c'est beau pourtant qu'il prend
des cats si ça marchait c'était
tellement bouquet prendrait quatre ça
cavaliers prends mes quatre ça cavaillé
prendra machin voyage
c'est dommage ça marche pas
cramé j'ai trop envie de le faire tant
pis j'ai trop envie
et après surtout reproches faits
recueillis pour un f3 fou prend f3 tour
prend d un fou prend des inquiets
pranger quatre rangées cattin jeu peut
être pas si mal prise j'ai qu'as-tu fait
prise f3 prise d un ouais c'est ça je
fais prise à froid prise d un comme ça
je prends sur échec
je prends ici je prends sur échec et je
fais 3 bis et 8
et là j'ai quoi j'ai deux pièces de moi
pas mais je suis complètement con je
suis complètement con complètement con
[Rires]
aïe aïe aïe ah je suis complètement
débile j'avais vu que ça marchait pas
mais bon j'ai voulu y croire moi même
voilà il ya assez tait c'est trop beau
pour être vrai
heureusement que ça m'amuse parce que
c'est pas très drôle cette finale avec
deux pièces de moins alors est ce qu'on
peut faire quelque chose de pièges dois
vous dire ça me par un peu sévère quand
même esprit sportif et là t'es pas si
mal wells il a quand même c'est horrible
ça visuellement je peux peut-être pas si
mal parce que ça peut donner cette
impression en fait ce qui a des pions
mais en fait c'est horrible tel beau jeu
qu'on aimerait c'est pas très dur à
gagner avec les blancs mais bon
va-t-il y arriver
j'essaie de pousser comme je peux mais
pions
je vais g4 pour pouvoir faire h5 et
maintenant je peux peut-être faire f4f
trois points de façon jeu de tintin et
rigide il vient et ça paraissait
complètement foutu de base et je
comprenais pas trop pourquoi ça l'était
pas voilà j'ai trouvé un peu de contre
eux je mal gré mais deux pièces de moins
mais bon c'est tout match de pièces
alors lui mettre la pression à proposer
nul qui veut garder sa pièce de plus
c'est un peu dangereux là ce qui fait
honnêtement et anne comme toujours en
finale pas terrible ce que tu faire
ce que d'une finale facile à gagner il
est passé à un truc gagnant certes mais
plus difficile
malheureusement
c'est quand même gagnants
malheureusement pour moi bien évidemment
ça s'appelle direct au caire
mais moi j'ai plus de temps
mais m'a laissé des chances et anne que
j'aurais pas dû avoir
le truc c'est que
j'avais rien jamais nulle pas en fait
quoique
plus assez de temps pour le finir sinon
jo l'arnaqué arriver joe l'arnaqué la
boum jo larnack jo larnack geôles
arnaque les tontons les tontons les
pions passé les pions passé la finale
avec deux pièces de plus on est là on
étale en sueur et anne en sueur et allez
on se fait plaisir et les pions passé
qui sont passés ils étaient là ils
étaient trois ils étaient trop forts
il était trop fort il était trop fort
les pions il était là ils étaient tous
là il était méchant
ils sont allés au bout ils sont aller à
dame
ils sont allés à l'âme des quatre pions
passé les finales les tontons les
finales
elle fait plaisir celle là elle fait
plaisir ses enfants alors un avec une
qualité de plus haute avec deux pièces
[Musique]
sa griffe ou jallet mouchoir pour ma
main attention et thann quand on parle
de mouchoirs à ton âge on pourrait
penser à autre chose fait quand même
très attention la chance du blenda afin
les bien sûr mais bien sûr la chance
toujours les amis toujours la chance
mais bon tu méritais de gagner
tu mérites et de la gagner
avec 100 la princesse qui veut jouer de
partout alors là on perd une dame
bon j'ai vu quand je les jouais en fait
on perd la dame alors c'est d'arnaqué
c'est avec une dame deux mois n'en perd
pas la dame madame dessin je vois plus
rien je vois plus rien j'ai peut-être
une envie de trop envie de donner la
dame en fait et d'amd 5
ces trois on est prêt à donner la dame à
tout moment les amis on est prêt à
donner la dame est ce qu'on en voit la
dame ou pas conditions serait un poil
meilleur j'aurais bien envoyé la dame
quand même mais bon on n'en voit pas
on est prêt à envoyer on est prêt à
envoyer est-ce qu'on peut envoyer
maintenant trente pas
mais là c'est dur quand même si on voit
la dame là on peut pas fréquent un poil
plus de matos pour l'envoyer cette dame
c'est pas l'envié qui manque un mec
super mal c'est horrible catastrophe
cette position
brutalement match complètement fou tu
quoi c'est génial bon alors on va
attaquer sa comment on va s'y prendre
comment va-t-on s'y prendre pour
arnaquer sa femme là c'est quand même
dur là c'est encore peut-être pire
encore le gers en fait tous les deux
tant que je perds pas en fait je joue
des poubelles de pire en pire c'est
génial d'aller d'un premier set c'était
tellement con comme coup la city n'a
envoyé cette dame j'aurais dû le faire
est prête sainte reine
non mais c'est horrible
entre rock
c'est écrit c'est le challenge gagne
qu'une poubelle quand même vu allouer
font pas quand même vl mais bon gagner
avec une poubelle point barre les
cavalières trois bons ballons un peu sur
le clouage du coup tu es mon chum a
rendu avec des poubelles c'est plus
marrant de jouer avec une poubelle
ok je faisais de prendre la finale là
quand même parce que ça c'est un rêve
par rapport à la position que j'avais
c'est le bonheur de jouer ça
même si je suis pas encore sorti mais
bon ok je vais laisser le pion m
d'emprise je vais vite m'activer je vais
mettre en jeu parce que sinon j'ai pas
de pièces en jeu c'est chiant et comme
ça je m'active à fond est ok il y joue
in here is who is who il a voulu prendre
le pion f2 et du coup il se prend il se
prend la fourchette et cavaliers qui
tombe elle a été gourmand fishie il a
voulu manger mon pions et là du coup il
dit c'est le bagne adore j'ai même pas
fou et trois échecs
il y joue craquelle championnat pour
fixer la chante la ola chants que la
totale
et allez prendre le pion il va laisser
m'activer avec une tour en d1 et un
cavalier en c3 on l'a mis en sueur ici
il sous x ou y y puis ici il sous la
chante là
pas de chance on rejoue et anne faire
quatre écoutes on va lui faire cette
petite variante avec des quatre saeco
n'est pas sûr d'anne decis p4 et l'a
jamais vu ça c'est une expansion allen
dame de folie saahlm est en sueur ne
vous inquiétez pas là on sent la sueur
devant cette poussée pions bah ça fait
suer c'est tous ses pions hills où je
pense qu'il aurait dû juste bouger
ok mont noir ok on peut développer une
pièce allez on va se développer à fond
mes impressions sur cinq
c'est le bagne adore aller hop comme ça
on tape un pion déjà ça s'est fait comme
ça ça c'est fait déjà le pion de plus il
est là il ya les amis c'est noël salua
zéline qui est nouveau ici saluton tôt
freddy bambo comme un cavalier f5 un peu
attaqué le truc fou et 6
on est ici pas de chance bîmes
ça marche peut-être pas par contre
il était juste tour des huit qui défend
pas de chance pas de chance pas de
chance
c'est vraiment pas de chance on va faire
tout en français 5 ont envoyé et en fait
on ferait un truc marrant au lieu de
prendre la fuite pour gagner la call of
c'est tellement ennuyeux de regagner la
kalach jeu avec deux pions de plus pour
les joutes tête avec deux pions plus ou
pas bon je vous prends à sept et on fait
du issoufou a mais il veut faire cailler
g4 en fait il est malin et anne attendez
attendez attendez des seuils de
m'arnaquer là c'est pas drôle à faire
j'ai trois ils essayent de m'arnaquer
c'est quand même pas gentil ça et
méchant est un il est méchant il est
méchant
il est très méchant ils essayent
d'arnaqué non il faut pas mal j'ai pas
mal
35 c'est pas si simple c'est pas si
simple en réalité c'est pas si simple
tout n'est pas si facile tout ne tient
qu'à notre style
allez il souffre quand même deux pions
plus on a plus ou moins stabilisé là ça
devrait aller d'un match 3
mais crée pas vraiment de menaces en
réalité m la tour on va jouer la colonne
ouverte facebook at-on affaire f3 il
faut faire gaffe parce que ce faisant ce
petit jeu là il peut être dangereux donc
message avez vu vous savez quoi
si j'ai pas bien calculé depuis le début
de la variante c'est bien fait pour ma
gueule quoi ma gueule
mais qu'est ce cas-là mayer si j'ai pas
bien calculé depuis le début c'est bien
fait pour ma gueule je re calcule pas
pas de chance mais je crois que ça va
normalement ça va ya pas de maths en un
le roi va partir et ann curry c'est une
magouille et mais je n'ai pas peur de
toi je n'ai pas peur de toi et anne bon
sur d'un machin faut surtout pas faire
d'alger 1 puisque red à metz 3 mais je
vais faire roi deux dames âgées de roi
des indes un broyage trois rois c1
le roi va partir en b2 il y aura plus
d'échecs
mais mon roi va être protégés dans un
rock sera l'équivalent baroque de
l'autre côté est allé weight and key ce
seuil est à essayer de jardin kg et est
malin il est malin il est malin il est
malin il avait repris la tête vide
tournons en gagnant rapidement des
parties en plus ça il est fort y est
fort ce métal et ça n'a pas suffi ça n'a
pas suffi 10 chf vicieux et participer
au tournoi je vais un petit lien et
toutes les explications vicieux rohff
aller be mine scandinave manier
shoichiro filet chaud ils sont tous choi
sont touchera les prends le pion ils
sont tous chauds comme une attaque et ça
allait essayer de nous arnaquer et 1 il
a quand même essayé d'allonger dans les
pièges ça soulève et a tenté un joli
piège da kg 4 veillant à sa marche pas
ça marche parlé c'était bien joué a été
solide en solide
tu joues pas mal a les caisses qui me
fait rire fou des six fours
allez
il me pousse les pions ce parc à me
faire petit rock c'est rien vient
m'attaquer et allez on fait f prend à
les boums on prend on prend vers les
côtés alors on est chaud on échouera
faire qui est des cinq issoufou
comment il s'en sort pas mal hein en une
fois ici
quand même perdre 1 à 5 ces trois dames
35 y avait des sites d'un prend b2 ok
mais la foulée 4g fou g3 aussi j'avais
fou g3 aussi 3d je sais pas les fauves
et 4 par ce que je menace là je menace
là je menace partout et ouais ça à venir
ça va venir et anne faut se battre
faut il croire c'est ta chance c'est
comment déjà cette chanson c'est pas
chanson le fou c'est 600 prix c'est jean
jacques goldman baie d'alger deux dames
f3 et victoria of en sueur y subit sur
ryloth issue issue à grosses gouttes à
les tontons arrête de suez abandonne et
bild ap g de roisin et boum attend point
f1 maths en vain allez le souffle de
partout
allez on souffle de partout le fou c'est
600 prises
varta gbii mot 4e joue tous des
scandinaves ils sont complètement par et
bim
qu'est ce que c'est que cette merde d'un
nul 6 échecs qu'est-ce qui fait var tac
boum cavaliers f3 il fait quoi ton tadam
c'est quoi cette scandinave art acté un
nouveau sur la chaîne c'est quoi le
problème c'est qu'il patron c'est qui le
patron bartak je fous un peu de la
gueule avec qui et 12 127
vous allez me dire je passe un peu pour
un connard maintenant gg 1300 points de
plus je t'emmerde
c'est plus fort que toi rien à [ __ ]
c'est génial tu plus de points que toi
j'en profite pour t'humilier très
attention bîmes cinq ans mais bon la sq
ont ils auraient pu connaître quand même
ça ils regardent la chaîne
d'où la découverte sur la dame
ouais c'est plus vaart accès artaq bien
sûr et poupées cinq échecs trois des
huit cavaliers sept matches ça va
arriver les amis les amis gilles martin
qui va casser une télé c'est la défaite
à la pour bartak les amis null null null
null
il a été nul varta que j'avais annoncé
le mad bartak lui n'avait trouvé faire
d'un bassin et franchement marre taclant
mais je t'aime bien en fait hein mais
bon dame à cinq quand même merde quand
même quand même j'aurais pu le faire
marc takla tu me fais du dames 6 échecs
la même toi tu envie de [ __ ] de ta
gueule on regarde blue en garde l'union
gargar regarde super génial tu prends tu
le prends pas eu tension je vais faire
ça je dis ça je dis rien je me lasse
m'attendais on ne sait pas s'ils veulent
atteindre
ça aurait pu marcher on ne sait pas
alors est ce qu'on re menaces
m'attendais ou pas allez soyons fous
non mais là c'est deux fois matin ça
aurait pu marcher on ne sait pas mal et
on recule allez-vous match 4 j'aime bien
ce matin
quadrillage 3 mais le cas est sur le
banc très fort et sur le bord qu'il est
très fort je vous mets pièce je suis là
on peut y aller car être je me bats dans
super génial il est chaud la super
chiant coiffe un foyer heureux super
génial oh ils échangent des dames et ben
tu sais quoi rien pour te faire chier je
les ai changé
j'ai deux pions loin j'en ai rien à
[ __ ] cet échange les dames c'est rien
que pour te faire chier super génial je
t'échange les dames
ça te fait chier rien que pour le faire
chier je lui ai changé les dames il n'en
peut plus tu as voulu jouer au con je te
les échanges et tu fais quoi maintenant
pas pu les dames mais bon il a voulu
jouer au con avec moi super génial
fallait pas jouer au con va dire que tu
as fait avec deux pions de plus va dire
je vois comme un jouet quand tu vas les
v10 vient gagner la finale tu fais ça je
ferai des deux tepa convoi je t'emmerde
tu mettes matour en développe des pièces
je fais qu'aller c4 tellement je suis là
bas et ses souffrances et calvi 3,8 boom
dégage alors on fait moins le malin
super génial en finale à super génial
super gars c'est le fil des lego là les
lego complètement conquise super génial
super revenir vers c'est moins le malin
la super génial vous jouez au coin avec
quoi ils voient y voit il voit ce qu'il
en ressort
si tu as les arènes francophone de
bullet ou trois minutes ouais on va
pouvoir faire ce qu'on veut en fait donc
on le fera mais bon un peu attendre
super génial ion sur il s'est dit j'en
aurai final les deux pions de plus là il
est en train de se dire je me foutait de
la gueule des tania dix minutes je fait
moins le malin
je suis un chat fait attention il est ou
super génial et ce qui est dans le tchad
super génial il en sueur total il s'est
dit lui rentrant d'une finale y aura
plus trop de tactique
tu te jure je te jure il s'est dit ça je
te jure il s'est dit je rentre dans une
finale c'est moins tactique permet
vraiment les mecs il s'est vraiment
dijon dans une finale y aura moins de
tactique 3 quoi après hyper une call of
c'est sa réalité quoi c'est la réalité
super génial
alors c'est malgré tout pas fini il va
falloir de nouveau un peu se concentrer
ensuite rien dans le chat il écoute
sa réalité à super finale c'est les faux
échec alors à temps est-ce que alors
j'ai le choix entre jouer un bon coup
tenté un piège qu'on tente un piège
qu'on est évidemment le coup que je vais
jouer on avait le choix
on ne peut cependant la mère d'un [ __ ]
je suis à grosses gouttes la niveau de
connerie de ce coup c'est quand même
violent a pu tant il a vu hashim al amel
il écoute il écoute le strip hutin il
savait que je tentais un piège qu'on a
je voulais faire voir à revoir sa
qualité 8
[ __ ] je suis mal
enfin je me replie
choix pourtant
il écoute il écoute [ __ ]
cavalli est malin il souffre il souffre
mon cavalier à l'écrit this tu trouves
que tu existes
oh oui oh oui oh oui n'allait pas sortir
il n'allait pas sortir il va échanger
il l'a échangé il m'a échangé il m'a
échangé aux lionel messi contre
mitroglou il a pris me trouble où tu
l'as acheté aux baumettes me trouble où
tu as pris mitroglou pour messi et c'est
la vérité les amis et c'est la vérité et
c'est la vérité les amis il a recruté
mitroglou il a recruté mitroglou il me
l'a échangé contre mais si les mains en
gelée plus mitroglou et je pousse à 4 et
je vais mettre la tour en 1 et je vais
pousser à 5 et je vais pousser à 5 et ya
plus de microbes ou sur le terrain et
j'ai plus valère germain et c'est fini
il n'en peux plus j'ai tôt 20 meilleurs
potentiels d'europe il va finir plus
fort que lionel messi est allé on va
mettre la tour 1 on va pousser il peut
plus l'arrêter les amis et s'ils
arrêtent on se décale on va le faire
tomber les amis on n'a aucune race on a
pas de race les amis ont fait tomber on
en a rien à [ __ ]
mais oui vas-y gagne les pions s'en fout
total on va te faire tomber
on joue que la pendule on ne veut plus
que la pendule les amis on ne joue plus
aux échecs on joue plus que la pendule
on est les pierres pourriture du monde
et on a joué la pendule et du coup on
l'arnaqué et c'est la vérité les amis on
a en a quinze jours la pendule état et à
le niveau 2 sur des tables dans cette
partie il est écoeuré et annie l'on peut
plus et allez on va lui faire un truc
hyper conceptuel boom cavalier e 4 spa -
neveu ne refaites jamais ça
guy g5 les talents sueur déjà 5 et à
l'issue la ilaha illa j'avais vu ça il
s'est dit je fais des systèmes de
londres fut tranquille
bon alors ce qu'on a fait c'est
complètement de la merde mais j'aurais
dû prendre en g3 plus tôt mais bon le
système de londres visiter
il en peut plus et anne on se développe
pas on se développe on se développe
prendre ici
voilà ça fait un peu le ménage
vive l'amour entre pas dans une finale
on est sympa
il
ils échangent les dames et anne et anne
ils échangent les dan il se prend la
paire de fou dans la gueule direct
c'est quoi le matériel et anne c'est
quoi le matériel ta pâte qui ont de plus
comment on peut le mettre en sueur
quand on peut être éteint en sueur ici
moi j'ai envie de m'amuser
pas simple à jouer pour les blancs un
fouet trois histoires de l'empêcher de
rock et de faire des conneries avec le
fou
c'est de le maintenir dans une cage
on va perdre à la cage des tannes
toujours donner un nom à vos cages
qu'est-ce qui fait des cinq comme ça je
prendrai des deux je prendrais 4 et
récupérer des 5
à
il me laisse pas le
le mettre à mal si facilement
il me laisse pas le mettre à mal si
facilement
j'aurais aimé être plus gagnant
c'est tendu pour lui quand même
travis ensemble
s'en est sorti bon j'aurais pu avoir en
plus c'est tout mais je voulais j'ai
voulu jouer le beau jeu
ethan s'en est sorti mais non il s'en
est pas sorti la rue une pièce en a ils
arguent une pièce en bout en bout le
piège qui a fini par passer âgées les
garder sous pression à un moment assez
t'es sûr que ça finirait par passer
moi j'aurais pu faire fut grande et de
fou prend le cadre plus tôt mais bon il
en sueur de nouveau mais allez on monte
change rien et à l'on n'échange pas de
pièce dans une nouvelle décision
complètement convient de prendre votre
came obligés
tarifs 7 tours prend fois fuite b5 comme
ça à voir prendre la prendre là
à leogane propres
on va tenter un truc marrant
c'est ça marche pas mal heureusement
où ça marche
capable de plus être gagnant à force et
un mais surtour ici je veux faire fou
ici est menacée tour matt imparable j'ai
des idées quand même j'ai des idées dans
la vie ça marche pas
on s'est mis dans la merde tout seul en
voulant s'amuser et on va peut-être pas
la gagner tracé plus gagnant par va
faire nul les mecs on va être obligé de
faire un nul
aïe aïe aïe
bon
ça va faire nul dommage
aïe aïe aïe on a voulu faire beau ou
alors il fallait juste gagner la partie
mais bon dommage dommage j'aurais fait
les fairways set a enfoncé un coin
changé il n'est pas du tout réussi ce
normal dommage pas de chance pas de
chance c'est la dernière partie du soir
pour nous
démonstration nippon à ethan du coup ça
pas fonctionné désolé les thann j'ai
voulu finir bougeait pas réussi pas
évident de faire beau à chaque fois des
fois ça se retourne contre moi
on sent que la journée a été longue
ouais je suis pas cynique cynique aux
siens c'est faire des beaux trucs mais
ça n'a pas fonctionné prendre la fuite
finir là-dessus mais gagnera pas le
tournoi
qu'est ce que j'ai
qu'est-ce qui fait
jugeons-en battre le projet de briques
de gravelle mois d'août on en refait une
dernière
der des ders au nom repos bien mérité et
misez pas follow la chaîne chaise com fr
n'hésitez pas à faux la chaîne chaise
com fr or mon échec en sueur
ou pas d'ailleurs
un peu de mes envies de budapest n'avait
pas le candidat ps je n'ai pas du tout
en fait on va pousser encore sur l'ale
est ce que roman échec su j'espère bien
qu'issue roman échec
et le gambit l'éléphant joue pas non
plus tech pas grand chose hein
normand échec ça joue vite la main
un tas de tintin je t'aime paul maximum
j'espère qu'ils prennent s'en va lui
ouvrir le roi
et là bim et bim allait faire cailler h4
allait peut-être le temps pour in der
des der on les enchaîne sans a marqué
quelques petits points à il prend pas le
pion
à y en a marre ça vient du continent
suite d'un fort reste et tu turin faut
rester
à l'étape a voulu prendre de matériel
des gages à je vais faire g5 bien
évidemment
et ce qui va se défendre normalement oui
mais on va voir
moi à voir on va voir c'est juste goody
il sait se défendre
commence déjà à craquer
darko ristic se défend maintenant
tu peux essayer des moves foule assez
que des mouches de merde là c'est que du
cacao des swatch non je veux pas sérieux
on joue pour envoyer du matos pour pour
s'amuser tu vois je pense qu'il prend
des quatre ça marche mais j'ai pas bien
calculé
pendant sa marche pas
je pense qu'elle est dam des trois qui
étaient plus forts bon du coup on a fait
n'importe quoi
et on va essayer de gagner cette finale
avec une pièce de moins
baal est pas clair cette finale
elle est pas clair
f4 j'aime pas du tout son cours je vais
prendre
il va apprendre j'ai fait re 5 qui me
laisse pousser mes pions en fait ok
on va pousser pousser même à laisser les
pions payer les pions passé
allez on va essayer de monter le roi
va pas laisser faire cavalier f5 on va
donner ce pion et on va monter le roi
quand même encore il me laisse une
fourchette discrète
c'est pas du tout sûr que je la gagne
je pense que carey eux aussi c'est un
peu naïf ce que maintenant sur tours g20
f3 que j'avais pas tout à l'heure je
pense qu'il fallait commencer par tour
g2a préfère qu'elle réussisse pour
mettre le roi sur la bande
est-ce que je vais refaire f3 je vais
pouvoir prendre de l'espace
je vais faire 3 je prends encore plus d
espace je veux faire h5 je vais prendre
encore plus des espaces ça je peux faire
h4 pour prendre encore de l'espace
je vais faire un tour en 1 6
ok
je vais retour 4
ça reste chaud
encore prendre de l'espace donc à point
de l'espace jeunes du roi g3 avant
d'ailleurs si je vais faire ça donc un
apprenti à prendre l'a1 qui est
intéressant
il ya pas mal joué en fait
partir là bas avec la tour
il a par un jouet du tout en fait avec
les blancs contre les pions
c'était pas fou parce que si j'encaisse
lui est peut-être dû faire caler des
trois qui essaient 5
on lit dans le chat que c'est drôle je
demande à voir quand même tu vois je
demande à voir si ces nuls ou pas toi tu
dis que c'est nul moi je dis j'en sais
rien
que ta roll nous a laissé
je demande à voir
waouh
surprend bessette et ses seins qui tente
encore un piège qu'est-ce qu'ils sont
piégeurs ce soir à 80 plus d'un vrai que
moi encore
incroyable ses enfants la der des der
des der c'est encore un petit écart et
on utilise de l'arrivée quand même bien
classés faudrait qu'on le joue à un
genou contre arthur à je me trompe de
cases finir là-dessus bien sûr un joueur
assez fort malheureusement j'ai envie de
dire
évidemment j'ai envie de jouer une
partie tranquille pour finir je peux
claque et là je suis en grande forme ce
fut de première fraîcheur
ça use les commentaires à force donc je
préfère un adversaire plus simple
surtout que j'aurais dû jouer des quatre
plutôt bien joué de sa part il a bien
utilisé mon erreur
bon allez on est là pour s'amuser les
mecs ce qu'il faut jamais oublier qu'on
veut jouer aux échecs c'est que vous
êtes là pour vous amuser moi j'ai envie
de larguer une pièce je largue une salle
et on est là pour rire
on est là pour rire on est là pour se
faire plaisir on est là pour envoyer du
matériel
[Musique]
ou pas
un peu craignos mais bon
allez cette année
alors
vu que je baise ou soit dame prend des
cats et une intuition me dit de faire
[ __ ] en d5 en premier je devais pas
suivre mon intuition dégage intuition de
merle dégageant tution de merde
faisons confiance aux calculs
[Musique]
comment faire maintenant ça j'arrive
plus à calculer par contre faire
confiance aux calculs ou calcul sans
réussir à calculer c'est pas facile mais
on va développer les pièces on va
essayer de ramener les tours en jeu
m la tour en d1 pour le moment
un petit peu cloud et tout ça
ça fera pas de mal
la tour qui vient s'en mêler
tu vas faire flouer 6
j'arrive plus à calculer c'est horrible
non ok je veux damage 3 je pensais m'en
prendre option à vii en fait au prochain
comme ça de gagné une partie vient en
force une jolie partie peut-être pour
finir si on la gagne c'est une jolie ce
que j'ai fait avec les gens de soulary
mhadjou en fête avec eux à la fois mais
bon je sais pas tu vois je suis pas trop
insistants pour faire des lives quoi
s'ils veulent faire des live kontakt
euros - qui sont chauds je suis chaud
en tout temps l'animal autant savait que
si on le bas et ça nous arrangerait de
de lui casser le strict pour gagner le
tournoi c'est vrai ça paraît tellement
il ya utilise le live qui qui est proche
tours 7
en trois sets
une catastrophe je n'arrive pas à
calculer mais je vais faire x 3
faut que j'arrive vraiment la sauvage
quoi
enfin
pas un truc et jolie marche pas
c'est cruel les échecs quand tu veux
faire des beaux trucs
je voulais faire dame prend fou prend
1,7 et fou prend 17 dame prend 17 3 est
la finale afin été perdante
c'est écrit c'est cruel c'est cruel des
fois la vie est cruelle pour les gens
qui veulent envoyer des pièces là on
aura envoyé quand même
j'avais pas finir la partie comme je le
souhaite mais magie des menaces quand
même tu as tout reprend ses six tours 8
j'en ai partout
vincent a testé ça peut être une belle
partie pour finir un bout en bout ce
match parce que j'avais vraiment envie
de gagner
du coup pas de blague
justin ce match parce que tu reprends
ses six dames à 6 ou des six matches ce
serait sympa bon ok on va finir ça à la
va vite
qu'est-ce qui est même le plus sévère je
ferai encore plus sévère c'est fou prend
la fuite
tam profite pour qu'on n'essaye même pas
de sacrifice de dames dans la fois être
sérieux il ya de la fatigue
il faut ce match et là
là c'est un ce match
là on a ce match et met pas mal dans la
partie j'ai bien aimé le la d4 quand
même qu'il prend que l'on prend est tout
un échec boom tue pas l'air si ça ça
fonctionne à l'aide de l'ordinateur et
du coordinateur de merde je le faire
tourner au revoir vous voyez plus trop
l'écran là tu peux corriger
on va voir ce qu'il dit
peter limacher qui n'a jamais sacré vrai
mais je voir si leur dit que c'était bon
pas et on va se quitter là dessus et on
va se quitter là dessus on aura fait un
petit peu de
un peu de rab c'était marrant non je
pense que vous avez pensé des parties
marrante mirtahsmab mentionné un
commentaire
arrêté dans sur reste assez assez assez
sûre en ce truc que je t'ai fait fusil
libériens dit merci qui avait n'oubliez
pas de follow la chaîne chaise comme et
la chaîne bitstream aussi du coup de
folie les deux chaînes dont mais cette
analyse
pour voir si les quartiers prend des cas
tout quoi qu'est ce qu'il raconte là
dessus j'en profite pour un truc
en tant que
c'est fondamentalement assez correcte
mon truc j'ai juste cela ils disent
plutôt de faire [ __ ] en d4
bah ça pourquoi mais en fait c'est pas
c'est un mauvais mauvais en fait ce que
j'ai fait marc en moins sur ce les mecs
merci d'avoir suivi bon courage à ceux
qui lisent le tournoi je vais sûrement
est rattrapé par max roche
youkilis de live mais bon pas de chance
j'aurais fait ce que je pouvais et
et à demain 13h sur la chaîne vitrine
pour la dernière fois il faut retenir
monde de rapides merci ciao ciao